I just have one question
when cap needed help if I'd asked you
would you have come I guess we'll never
know but if you had you'd have never
been caught
[Music]
I do some dumb things and the people I
love the most they pay the price thanks
to you we had to run
we're still running let's go
[Music]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
linked a partner
hold on you gave her wings and blasters
so I take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
hey everybody marble is buzzing with the
sound of the wasp ant-man and the wasp
finally got our first trailer did not
expect them to drop at this soon but
last night at the Black Panther premiere
they were just doing all the regular
Instagram stories you would expect like
check out all this awesome stuff that's
going on because Black Panther is
freaking awesome but then like right at
the end of the night the Instagram
account was just like panning across all
the banners on the red carpet then BOOM
trailer tomorrow so I love the way that
they tie this to Civil War because
obviously this is gonna be happening
this summer if you guys didn't know the
movie's coming out July 6 so what's
happening is is in a couple weeks we're
gonna get Black Panther then a couple
months after that we get infinity war
and then a couple months after that we
get ant-man and the wasp then we go into
2019 with Captain Marvel Avengers 4 you
know whatever Infinity Gauntlet title
they give to that and then spider-man
homecoming 2 so it is gonna be crazy for
the next 18 months with big Avengers
level Marvel stuff going on but in
between that you have all these other
cool solo movies so naturally they're
gonna try and tie this to what's going
on during infinity war but the cool
thing about this movie in addition to
the fact that the wasp is a total badass
is that they're bringing Janet Van Dyne
back into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now she was in the first movie but you
really only saw a version of the costume
and the funny thing about the trailer is
is that they tease them being on the run
because of what happened during civil
wars so I'll explain a little bit about
the plot because they're still really
ambiguous about where this happens
relative to infinity war because these
characters are involved in the next two
Avengers films but as you can see the
only thing in the trailer that actually
places this in the timeline is the way
they talk about civil war happening in
the past well if you two brought me
along then you wouldn't have been caught
so you have to imagine that somehow
Janet Van Dyne comes out of the quantum
realm not having known everything that's
happened since Marvel phase 1 I think it
was technically during the 80s that
flashback during the first ant-man film
because it was during the Cold War that
she went down into the quantum realm to
take down that bomb that Hank Pym said
he was never able to find her again
so I'm guessing what'll happen is is
when they released the next trailer
that's when we'll finally see Michelle
Pfeiffer as the wasps come out of the
quad
- realm but you do see a little bit of
that tiny ship so that might be how they
get her out but I'm curious to see if
some of the villains stuff we see going
on during the trailer also has something
to do with the quantum realm because
thinking about micronauts the whole idea
is is that there is a civilization that
lives on that level there's life down
there but in the way Doctor Strange
teased the idea of multiple different
realms the multiverse we're just slowly
pushing into that so I don't know how
much the villain in the movie is going
to be tied to that or how much of the
side plot that's going to be but the
main villain of the movie is walton
goggins we've known about that for a
while we finally found out who he's
playing though it's Sonny birch and if
he doesn't sound familiar it's because
he's a relatively minor character but
he's something in the vein of Obadiah
Stane so think somebody who's another
one of those government contractors that
sells weapons the way that Tony Stark
stopped doing that
stop being a dirtbag I love the way that
ulysses klaw talked about him - that's
something that Tony Stark used to say to
me you're one of his so you just you
remember the Tony Stark used to hang out
in a lot of these weapons conventions
with these dirtbags that are now the
villains of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but for the most part the plot
of the movie is them on the run because
Hank Pym for the longest time like when
he quit shield during that flashback in
the first ant-man film he was because he
didn't want anybody even shield to get
their hands on his technology so they
had a little idea of what he was capable
of but because of the events of civil
war and all that cell phone footage that
got out like even Spiderman took cell
phone videos of their Airport battle now
everybody knows about Giant Man all the
crazy stuff that the Pym particles can
do so everybody wants their hands on it
the same way that everybody wants their
hands on that sweet vibranium honey but
team ant-man and the wasp are kind of on
their own because his company was kind
of destroyed at the end of the ant-man
movie so we'll see what's going on on a
corporate level because it sounds like a
lot of their technology starts leaking
out a little bit but I think what we're
all really interested to see is as if
Michelle Pfeiffer original wasp comes
out of the quantum realm will she and
Hank Pym get any badass original ant-man
in the wasp moments during the film
because you haven't seen Hank Pym in the
costume except during that flashback in
the first film but
whole idea they're teasing with this the
idea of ant-man and the wasp is that now
in present day he has a partner
he needs somebody to watch your back dad
but they did that back during the 70s
and the 80s with the original versions
of the characters so hopefully we'll
have some sort of moment like that but
just remember all the stuff that you're
seeing here this cool chase scene but
the fact that they're using an atom ant
rift I think it's ants on the March is
the name of the song which is just
hilarious there's this whole other plot
that's going on with the quantum realm
that we haven't seen yet but this is
probably Walton Goggins villain
character usually like whoever the
villain is from the comics you know
whatever they look like they get some
sort of crazy costume to like we got
with yellow jacket in the first ant-man
film but I do like the way that now
they're using that shrinking and growing
technology for more comedy the way they
did during civil war like he throws the
gas truck not knowing as a gas truck and
it almost kills a whole bunch of other
Avengers throw it at this
[Music]
oh man I thought it was a water truck
but in this you find out like hank pym
built a little suitcase handle into his
building then grew it up to normal size
just for this joke so that he could
wheel it away like it's some sort of
luggage that he's taking to the airport
like no big deal just gonna cart my
building away with all my technology
inside of it you also get a little bit
of the ant-man mobile it looks like they
have that shrinking and growing
technology the Pym tech built into the
car itself but the other really cool
thing here is you probably like Laurence
Fishburne what's he doing in this movie
who's he playing he's actually playing
Goliath who's sort of a secondary
version of giant man he was sort of like
a backup avenger that joined a later
version of the team but he perfected Pym
particles and tried to get rid of some
of the negative side effects that drove
Hank Pym crazy so the cool thing about
this though everyone says they want the
Netflix characters to crossover with the
movies in the comics his character was
married to Claire temple so it's just a
comic book Easter egg obviously that's
not gonna be the case in the movies so
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I think the way they're gonna use the
character is is that he's just somebody
who used to work with or alongside Hank
Pym who knows something about Pym
particles maybe he'll get to do some
cool giant man stuff in the future but
there's this whole idea that you have
the secret history of ant-man and the
wasp because Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne
used to be superheroes themselves a long
long time ago in all the stuff you see
with Scott Lang and hope Van Dyne is the
new version of the wasp is just the
resurgence of that so we'll see maybe
Laurence Fishburne who's a badass
himself will get to do some really cool
superhero stuff during the movie but
everybody let me know in the comments
what do you think of the trailers so far
obviously this is only showing us like
half of the movie we haven't seen Janet
Van Dyne yet so I think we're all just
waiting to see what she looks like
during the film and if there's gonna be
any crazy multiple dimension quantum
realm villains stuff going on but just
post all your questions in the comments
below I'll try to answer everything in
the comments obviously there's a lot of
black panther stuff happening in the
next couple of weeks the Superbowl
trailers will be dropping this weekend
so I don't know if we're gonna get a
brand new infinity war trailer probably
some new Marvel stuff whatever drops I
will totally do a video for it so no
worries so be sure to subscribe to get
every
and there is a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just share the video using the tools on
the watch page below so click here to
listen to Tom Hiddleston react to The
Avengers infinity war trailer and click
here for brand new black panther thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight